have new developments today in a story
we've been committed to for years now
it's about decades of exposure to toxic
water at a marine corps base in north
carolina the u.s government has
acknowledged what happened there for
nearly 35 years until 1987 those who
lived on the base were potentially
exposed to dangerous chemicals every
single time they drank the water swam in
the water or bathed in it but our cbs
news investigation found that many
families are still all these years later
looking for justice catherine herridge
has spoken to some of those families and
she joins us now from the pentagon
catherine good morning
tony good morning a bipartisan group of
lawmakers has introduced legislation
that would help thousands of military
families get accountability in the
courts for toxic exposure that goes back
generations
this is what we call baby heaven
tucked away in a remote corner of this
north carolina cemetery is row after row
of infant graves born october 6th
died october 7th
retired drill instructor jerry enzminger
was among the first to call out the
marine corps over toxic drinking water
at camp lejeune which is just down the
road from the cemetery what killed all
these children
it falls right within that period of
time when the water was contaminated
from 1953 to 1987 those serving at the
sprawling marine base were potentially
exposed to contaminated water for years
toxic agents seeped into the soil and
poisoned the groundwater at fuel depots
based junk yards even a dry cleaners
that since been demolished and
designated a hazardous site in some
areas tainted water was 400 times what
safety standards allowed when i first
heard about this it was like god opened
the sky up and said hey jerry
here's a possible answer to that
question that has nagged you for by that
time it was
14 15 years
in 1982 enzinger's six-year-old daughter
janie was diagnosed with leukemia was
toxic water to blame i blame it
janie passed in 1985 she was nine years
old she died on tuesday
was in the afternoon
you're a marine was this the hardest
thing you've ever had to live through
nothing
compares to
watching
one of your kids
suffer
and go through hell
and i blame the marine corps and
department of navy
while the marine corps declined an on
camera interview their experts showed us
the ongoing cleanup at camp lejeune
where they said the drinking water is
tested every day
but 40 years ago at this base housing
known as torowa terrace the water was
not safe enzinger lived there so did the
family of latrell watts when my dad
found out he called us he said that
water on camp lejeune was poisoned
that's where we lived at
military records show her father booker
was stationed at camp lejeune in the
mid-1970s when his wife was pregnant
with the trial you and your sister have
been sick over the years what about the
siblings who didn't live on the base
they're not sick with no family history
of breast cancer latrell questions why
it killed her mother at 42. this is
where she is buried at and latrell says
she struggles with chronic anemia and
reproductive issues the clock ran out on
these claims because the united states
government concealed it now the
government is saying
sorry
senator richard blumenthal introduced
the bipartisan camp lejeune justice act
that would address what senators call
unfair legal barriers that block
military families from suing the
government how many people are we
talking about
there are
thousands literally tens of thousands of
veterans who have very legitimate
serious claims
for injuries they've suffered cancer
parkinson's disease decades after camp
lejeune in hawaii last month the navy
says 4 000 families moved into temporary
housing after contaminated water was
discovered our children have been bathed
since saturday we have been bathing out
of bottled water an environmental
research group reports
385 military sites have contaminated
drinking water or groundwater a senior
defense official told cbs news they are
working with the group to determine the
most accurate data the pentagon ought to
do a national audit
of all its bases to determine where
there may have been contamination
where it continues and what can be done
to stop it i mean if this would have
been a corporation that did this their
asses would have been in
in court
decades ago
now working with the law firm the trail
watts is putting her faith in the
pending legislation and working through
her own pain by writing poetry the
babies of camp lejeune
that lay in their grave
that did not enlist but was kissed with
the poison
who will lay the claim
who will take the blame
a senior defense official tells cbs news
they're running hundreds of
investigations to make sure the water is
safe at military bases and they're
committed to be more transparent in the
future about their findings and the
actions they take nate
catherine thank you now you can't repair
the damage that was done
the lives lost but if there is an
acknowledgment of wrongdoing
you can
help these individuals well i think
they're looking for more than just i'm
sorry at this point right yeah they want
answers and they want accountability
just a specificity of the father saying
his daughter died on a tuesday it was in
the afternoon and all these years later
his pain is still palpable in the poem
that she just wrote right
just just the fact guys that there's a
grave that they call babies heaven
means there's something very wrong here
and you can write these wrongs yes
that's for sure all right